one of the worst programs in the history
of television is coming back on CNN
crossfire which ran on CNN from 1982 to
2005 which was basically a partisan hack
on the Left versus a partisan hack on
the right screaming at each other which
then led to all the bipolar dysfunction
we have in politics now it's coming back
to CNN and before we get into it let's
watch this is just a couple days before
they canceled the original crossfire Jon
Stewart went on there and laid in to the
hosts in many ways it's funny you know
and I made a special effort to come on
the show today because I have privately
amongst my friends and also in
occasional newspapers and television
shows mentioned this show as being bad
and and I wanted to I felt that that
wasn't fair and I should come here and
tell you that I don't it's not so much
that it's bad as it's hurting America
how old are you 35 and you wear a bow
tie yeah when you have people on for
just knee-jerk reaction airy talk I
thought you're gonna be funny come on no
no I'm not gonna be your monkey
i watch your show every day and it kills
me I can tell you what's so oh it's so
painful to watch you know because we
need what you do this is such a great
opportunity you have here to actually
get politicians off of their marketing
and strategy it's someone who watches
your show and cannot take it anymore
okay so I'm pretty sure crossfire was
canceled the next day they ended up
running it for a few more weeks but
Everett Jon Stewart hit that that was
you know about seven eight years ago and
everything that's wrong with our
political system is summed up in that
CNN's ratings are tanking and then the
new guy Jeff Zucker comes in and he's
bringing back and it's the worst kind of
awful with Newt Gingrich and SE Cupp
asking on one side and Van Jones and
Stephanie cutter on the other side first
of all the fact that Newt is leaving Fox
yeah I feel like CNN is like that dorky
AV Club table in high school you don't
even in then the bully from the Fox
tables like he's gonna come on he's
gonna come over and then here comes Newt
who he doesn't really think you're his
friends right but for some reason he's
leaving Fox oh that's suspicious why why
all of a sudden right is Newt Gingrich
leaving to go to CNN to start crossfire
again and the funny thing is with Newt
particularly not I mean this is going to
be the most tepid endorsement of Newt
ever but they made him out to be the
biggest joke when he was running all the
networks yeah so now to bring him on as
if as if he's some genius whether people
like them or not is kind of dissing
genuine by seeing it but what do you
think about this I I mean the reason I'm
doing this show is because I want to
show relatively smart people yourselves
included talking about issues not just
screaming with prepackaged talking
points and that's it's the last thing we
need it's nice to see CNN reaching out
at a time when Paula Deen is losing all
her shows and her Empire because of her
racism there again they're rewarding
certain other racists like Newt Gingrich
who's a blatant racist and also NBC is
still rewarding Donald Trump with a
racist show so Newt Gingrich if you're
telling me that calling the President
Barack Obama the Food Stamp president is
not race baiting in the worst form then
no you're dumb right that's why we're
smarter than you liar you're
disingenuous think about all those
people there's like dozens of them yeah
he also accused one Williams of not
knowing what work was about one Williams
a guy who at the time held three jobs
yeah notnot so that's just again this is
in and then but one Williams as far as
I'm concerned he's one of those guys who
goes over to the bully table and now you
got it coming yeah when you ask Newt
Gingrich to stop race-baiting in a room
full of Fox viewers they're gonna boo
you yeah
yes that's gonna happen that's a good
point about Juan Williams because he did
the reverse of what you're saying he
went to the so the cooler table and said
you know I'm not one of you guys on Fox
News and Here I am and I'm gonna fight
but do you guys think that part of this
has to do with the human brain I'm
starting to think this yeah yeah we have
two halves of the human brain we don't
have seven halves because that would be
mathematically impossible and our brains
are constantly fighting with each other
and because of that everything is now
man versus woman black versus white
right verse left but so that by putting
up a show like this they're just feeding
into something that's just wired into us
this constant battle of - why it's
wiring - funny mind step on you so
pretty man versus woman anyway but I
think of what it does it feel it feeds
into this notion that everything's equal
on both sides this false equivalency
yeah
oh there's blowhards on the right
there's low Habs on the left when in
reality one party we're in luck with two
parties really in America one party has
gone batshit crazy over the last 20
years so the point where it's
unrecognizable yet they still keep
reporting it as if it's the same equal
to say even the left has shifted to the
right so the Republican straight
Republicans are upset that their party
has shifted to the right and Democrats
are upset that their party has shifted
to the right yet the moves through the
mainstream news media reports it is
exactly the same as it was 20 years ago
yeah I think you are right about the the
two sides I feel like everything now
politically is push-pull you know I mean
so if we push this way they want
hold the exact same so even if if you
know like you've never been waterskiing
you don't water skiing good so if you if
you feel kind of like if you own the
water right you pulled yourself to keep
yourself up
what is automatically gonna happen just
the physics of it is that you're gonna
pull in the same distance and you're
gonna fall off your water skis that's
what's happening all the time
politically now is people get so upset
about nothing because they feel they
have to be if someone is passionate
about something like I don't know let's
say equality for gays right right a
civil equality we should all have people
who really could kind of care less or
like now whatever doesn't bother me but
because they feel that they're
Republicans and all of a sudden you know
my party is being you know somehow like
working attacked they pull even further
yeah do you know named when really
you're not that angry about it it
doesn't really affect your everyday life
why do you really care so much but they
feel that push-pull and so you're right
it's always these two halves that now
they're equally upset about something
that they're not really about you know
what it's funny because Bill Maher said
what both of you are saying he's been
saying this for years that the right
keeps going so far right and the left
because there's such a bunch of dogs
basically they just follow along with
the leash so what we used to think was
the middle is actually much further
right and it really got accelerated
during Bill Clinton Bill Clinton's you
know triangulation was I'll take all
these Republican issues and I'll make
them Democrat issues no no now you're
not a Democrat anymore yeah and so now
that's the shift to the right and again
it's just being reported as if it still
does choose two different liberal and a
conservative party when we have a
conservative and a more conservative
party yeah so okay so with all this
drivel almost every week on the show
we've talked about cable news and how
it's doing such a disservice and Jimmy
you have a show on The Young Turks
Network as well and I think this is one
of the few places where and of course
it's online which is why we're free and
we can speak our minds and all that
stuff what is the is the mainstream
media is it really just dead between we
know a you know MSNBC now is as bad one
way as Fox as the other and if CNN is
just going to give us the screaming is
it is it really just over and that may
really just be good for people like us
who are creating content on the
I think news should go back to one hour
a night that's it one show on I think
it's just to go back here's what
happened today yeah and that's a the
24-hour news cycle has destroyed
everything yeah and it's not really a
24-hour news cycle it's like every three
hours it just regurgitates itself
totally everyone says 24 hours but
actually they're just saying the same
thing on repeat eight times if you're a
comic ever been stuck in an airport
because your flights delayed before I
was watching the news in the airport you
know
oh we're just going right back to where
we were two hours ago and I really feel
like if we just just try to just try it
I say the big news corp just tried it
just a week let's do a little experiment
we just report the news like we used to
when I was a kid my parents watch the
news at night it was an hour long and
that was it lights out we're going to
bed so so last thought on this do you
think part of the problem also is that
because of these freaking trials that
they there's nothing more purely drivel
as' than to put a trial on for eight
hours a day to watch the minutiae of
what goes on in a court so they've been
doing that now for weeks and of course
we're gonna have weeks more now of
analysis but remember didn't wasn't a
North Korea gonna nuke us a month ago
wasn't they're gonna be there were
chemical weapons in Syria Egypt was
having a revolution I think a few days
ago does anyone know about any of that
like no I guess all that stuff just
worked out right they must 24-hour news
cycles they only take one hour and
devoted to news and the other 23 is
yeah and if they actually took
that time and did investigative reports
and you know documentaries and things
yeah that would be great but of course
they're not gonna do that
it's drivel drivel drivel because it's
the People magazine mentality of
television right now look at CNN it's
your joke
tips Tucker is his big ideas to bring
back the shittiest show they ever
and that's his idea have you
watched Erin Burnett my babysitter has
more depth than Earth unbelievable how a
child
the thinner than a pin oh that's how
that was an unnecessary shot at your
babies yeah it's unbelievable attached
to the me and you know what you talk
about MSNBC kind of being the mirror of
Fox they're not MSNBC still informs you
whereas Fox actively misinformed their
viewers on purpose they lighter their
own viewers on purpose they've been
caught many times it happens all the
time now it's not even worth pointing it
out but what MSNBC does is too often the
mainstream whatever the opinion is made
they're against Edward Snowden and MSNBC
they're for drone strikes yeah they're
doubt so that's what their problem the
problem is that MSNBC has is the same
problem our political system has is it's
one party right
you just have to latch on to the
administration because that's their guy
that's it all right last thought do you
think crossfire is coming back because
we have an election in a couple years I
think it's coming back purely because of
my date of its cut yeah great I think
truly is that the networks are afraid to
put on people that are intellectually
honest I think that's the truth you can
watch Hannity say the same things that
he hated about the NSA when or that he
loved when Bush was president and then
there's a great video on YouTube we
played it on the show and then now he
hates it because it's Obama and I think
they're afraid of just showing honest
people having or at least some degree of
intellectual honesty there's nothing